[Musica]
lasciate che vi faccia qualche domanda
quando è stata l'ultima volta che avete
preso un antibiotico era quello corretto
e levate veramente bisogno beh la
risposta è probabilmente no
secondo uno studio recente commissionato
dal governo britannico
circa il 70 per cento delle prescrizioni
antibiotiche non sono necessarie o non
sono specifiche ovvero quel antibiotico
che avete preso di recente è molto
probabile che non avevate bisogno o che
non era specifico per l'infezione che
avevate contratto e dovremmo
preoccuparci di questo problema
beh questa immagine dovrebbe essere
abbastanza esplicativa
se non lo è ciò che state osservando
sono delle piastre di suscettibilità
antibiotica che vengono comunemente
utilizzate per determinare l'efficacia
di diversi antibiotici nei confronti di
diversi batteri
ora le zone opache e lattiginose che
vedete su questi piatti sono batteri che
stanno crescendo su questa area su
questo disco e per testare l'efficacia
degli antibiotici vengono posizionati
quei dischetti bianchi che sono imbevuti
di antibiotico così che l'antibiotico
possa diffondere al di sopra del piatto
ed attaccare i batteri
ora sei l'antibiotico funziona i batteri
muoiono e questo è visibile come questi
aloni attorno ai dischetti bianchi nella
figura di sinistra questo però era
abbastanza vero per molti antibiotici
dieci anni fa al giorno d'oggi come
vedete uno di questi test appare più
come la figura di destra la quale ci
dice che i batteri stanno diventando
estremamente resistenti agli antibiotici
come potete vedere le zone lattiginose
adesso sono molto vicine ai dischi di
antibiotico il che vuol dire che i
batteri riescono a crescere anche in
presenza dell'antibiotico ma quanto è
importante quanto è grande per quanto è
grave il problema dello stesso studio di
cui parlavo prima ha cercato di
quantificare
le cause principali di morte per anno in
tutto il mondo tra cui potete vedere il
cancro diabete la diarrea e colera gli
incidenti stradali e l'antibiotico
resistenza che solamente nel 2014 ha
causato 700 mila morti in tutto il mondo
morti causate dal fatto che si
contraggono infezioni per le quali non
esistono più antibiotici che funzionano
ma ciò che è terrorizzante di questo
studio è che secondo alcune previsioni
questo numero potrebbe salire a 10
milioni entro il 2050
ciò che vi sto dicendo è che
l'antibiotico resistenza potrebbe
diventare il cancro del futuro ora
perché ciò accade perché è come i
batteri sviluppano resistenza
beh dovete sapere che i batteri sono
degli organismi minuscoli formati da
un'unica cellula e contenenti un l'unica
molecola di dna al loro interno ed è
proprio questa loro semplicità la chiave
del loro successo evoluzionistico e
proprio grazie a ciò che batteri
riescono a duplicarsi molto velocemente
e nel giro di poche ore
raggiungere i miliardi di individui
partito da un solo individuo iniziale
ora immaginiamo di voler uccidere questo
miliardo di batteri utilizzando un
antibiotico per esempio ora se tenete
conto di questi due fattori del fatto
che i batteri sono geneticamente
semplici e che sono miliardi e miliardi
e allora molto probabile che anche una
piccola mutazione casuale del dna riesca
a conferire resistenza anche un singolo
batterio quel singolo batterio adesso è
in grado per esempio di distruggere la
molecola di antibiotico o di espellerla
da all'interno della cellula così che
possa sopravvivere e una volta che ciò
accade il danno è fatto
perché quel singolo batterio adesso
dalla vita ad un intera discendenza di
batteri resistenti
stiamo parlando sostanzialmente di
selezione naturale la legge del più
forte quell'unico batterio che riesce a
sopravvivere avrà la meglio
e così faranno tutte le generazioni
successive dunque voglio mostrarvi
questo
dal vivo con un esperimento che è stato
realizzato qualche anno fa pubblicato su
science e in questo esperimento i
ricercatori hanno costruito un enorme
disco di suscettibilità come quello che
vi ho mostrato precedentemente ma
rettangolare è diviso in fasce verticali
in ognuna di queste fasce è presente una
quantità diversa di antibiotico
crescente da zero che scende verso
l'interno e ora come potrete vedere i
batteri vengono fatti partire
dall'estremità è come vedete crescono
abbastanza tranquillamente in assenza di
antibiotico e vengono arrestati alla
prima barriera dove è presente il
farmaco fin quando una mutazione emerge
quel singolo batterio riesce a mutare
casualmente riesce a proliferare
all'interno della prima delle prime
fasce esterne dove è presente
l'antibiotico e molte più mutazioni
iniziano apparire da tutte le parti
e questo accade nuovamente tra le man
mano che i batteri si spostano verso
l'interno dove la quantità di
antibiotico cresce tra 1 e 10 tra 10 e
come vedete proliferano e proliferano
fin quando in meno di dieci giorni dieci
giorni i batteri riescono a colonizzare
anche alla regione centrale dove è
presente una quantità di antibiotico
mille volte superiore a quella che
avrebbe ucciso i loro progenitori vecchi
di appena 10 giorni
spero siate d'accordo con me che questo
video da una parte terrorizzante perché
ci fa capire quanto grave e grosso il
problema effettivamente sia ma d'altro
canto è un video meraviglioso perché a
mio parere ci mostra quanto efficace ed
è una prova lampante della selezione
naturale e dell'evoluzione dei batteri
in questo caso dunque abbiamo capito che
il problema è del tutto naturale
selezione naturale
appunto ciao darwin ne parlava due
secoli fa già quindi cosa stiamo facendo
noi umani come specie umana come stiamo
interferendo beh sappiamo bene che noi
in quanto esseri umani siamo molto abili
nel interferire spesso negativamente
con processi del tutto naturali e questo
non è da meno il modo in cui stiamo
interferendo come immagino già saprete
risiede nell'utilizzo scorretto e
spropositato di antibiotici che facciamo
antibiotici ad ampio spettro antibiotici
non necessari per influenze virali per
esempio cicli antibiotici non terminati
tutti questi fattori forniscono i
batteri delle occasioni d'oro per poter
sviluppare resistenza forniscono delle
occasioni per quelle mutazioni genetiche
di avvenire ora perché quali sono i
meccanismi dietro questo utilizzo degli
antibiotici
ora la catena di diagnosi delle
infezioni prescrizione degli antibiotici
idealmente dovrebbe essere come questo
piccolo diagramma ora quando abbiamo una
sospetta infezione un nostro campione di
saliva urina o sangue per esempio viene
prelevato mandato ad un laboratorio per
un analisi microbiologica il cui scopo è
quello di identificare il migliore
antibiotico così da poterlo prescrivere
questo tipo di analisi microbiologiche
tuttavia viene spesso eseguita
utilizzando quei dischi di
suscettibilità di cui parlavo
precedentemente ciò che non vi ho detto
però è che questi dischi sono lenti
questi dischi impiegano dalle 24 alle 48
ore per poter fornire alcun risultato e
di conseguenza le prescrizioni
antibiotiche vengono fatte alla cieca e
basandosi semplicemente sull'esperienza
del medico questi risultati con questi
test o non vengono eseguiti o non se ne
attende il risultato proprio perché sono
troppo lenti e i motivi per cui questi
test sono lenti sono fondamentalmente
due da una parte utilizzano crescita
antibiotic crescita batterica come
indicatore ovvero se l'antibiotico
arresta la crescita funziona
altrimenti no ma la crescita batterica a
questo livello
impiega quel tempo e d'altro canto
questi test studiano miliardi di
organismi nello stesso testo
sostanzialmente fanno di tutta l'erba un
fascio
sappiamo bene che fare di tutta l'erba
un fascio spesso non è
la soluzione migliore anche nella vita
quotidiana dunque la domanda adesso è
what if
possiamo pensare ad un approccio
alternativo non approccio fuori dagli
schemi che possa riscrivere la diagnosi
delle infezioni
beh questo è quello di cui mi occupo in
quanto ricercatore presso l'università
di york e ciò che facciamo in
particolare a cercare di identificare
dei nuovi indicatori di suscettibilità
batterica ovvero cerchiamo di studiare
alcune proprietà batteriche che vengono
influenzate dagli antibiotici che
vengono attaccate e modificate dagli
antibiotici in tempi ristretti rispetto
alla crescita batterica
inoltre facciamo queste misure al
livello del singolo batterio ovvero
misuriamo i batteri uno per uno
ogni batterio è diverso da ogni altro e
questo deve essere tenuto in
considerazione per una corretta diagnosi
e in tutto ciò ci viene in aiuto la
microfluidica che è la scienza che ci
consente di controllare e manipolare i
liquidi nel quale nei quali batteri
vivono su scala micrometrica su scala
del milionesimo di metro e questo è il
dispositivo che utilizziamo e questo
dispositivo è costituito da un vetrino
dal microscopio sostanzialmente un pezzo
di vetro al di sopra del quale
fabbrichiamo delle piccole trappole in
verde queste piccole trappole agiscono
come delle micro di e delle micro
barriere per i batteri che vengono
iniettati attraverso questo tubicino in
modo che possano rimanere intrappolati
all'interno di queste barriere e poi
osservati utilizzando un semplice
microscopio da laboratorio e questo è
ciò che osserviamo ora qui potete vedere
in verticale il canale microfluidico
stiamo parlando ancora di milionesimi di
metro
abbiamo una un certo numero di queste
micro dighe le chiamerei quasi batteri
che nuotano e alcuni dei quali vengono
intrappolati all'interno di queste
trappole così che possiamo misurarli uno
per uno
le trappole sono minuti
ognuna riesce a contenere un singolo o
pochi batteri e adesso ciò che misuriamo
come dicevo non è la crescita batterica
è troppo lenta ci focalizziamo invece su
due proprietà batteriche molto
interessanti
la motilità ovvero l'abilità dei batteri
di nuotare di muoversi negli ambienti
liquidi e la morfologia ovvero la loro
forma ora dovete sapere che in assenza
di antibiotico dei batteri perfettamente
in salute sono dei nuotatori provetti
come potete vedere da questi video ed è
normale che lo siano perché ciò gli
fornisce un vantaggio evolutivo e
proprio grazie a queste abilità di
notare che riescono ad esplorare regioni
circostanti alla ricerca di nutrienti o
per attaccarsi a delle superfici o per
comunicare con altri batteri per esempio
e allo stesso tempo le loro forme sono
abbastanza regolari
il che è importante per mantenere un
equilibrio tra all'interno della cellula
è l'esterno
tuttavia nel momento in cui introduciamo
all'interno del dispositivo
l'antibiotico corretto e solo
l'antibiotico corretto i batteri non
sono più così bravi a nuotare
potete vedere che vengono ancora
intrappolati ma non si muovono più
attivamente perché l'antibiotico sta
interferendo con le loro funzioni vitali
non hanno più l'energia sufficiente per
poter nuotare in maniera efficace e allo
stesso tempo
l'antibiotico causa delle forme
abbastanza strane alcuni antibiotici
prendono i batteri più corti più lunghi
o con queste forme a v che sono tutti
degli indicatori di morte batterica ma
il punto chiave adesso e che non ho
bisogno di aspettare quelle 24 ore per
far crescere i batteri perché questi
cambi causati dall antibiotico vengono
avvengono e possono essere misurati in
appena un'ora quindi ciò che vi sto
dicendo che questo dispositivo potrebbe
essere in grado di identificare
l'antibiotico corretto è specifico in
circa un'ora
dunque per concludere l'idea che voglio
proporvi oggi che voglio portato a casa
e che in questo ciclo di diagnosi delle
infezioni e prescrizione degli
antibiotici
l'anello debole è rappresentato dalla
diagnostica la diagnostica e troppo
lenta non ci consente di individuare
dell'antibiotico migliore in tempi
ragionevoli e di conseguenza si abusa di
antibiotici
dunque ciò che bisogna riscrivere ciò
che bisogna ripensare è esattamente
l'elemento diagnostico e sostituire
queste queste piastre tradizionali con
dei metodi alternativi per esempio micro
critici di cui vi ho parlato ho anche un
sacco di altre tecniche che vengono
studiate dai ricercatori di tutto il
mondo spesso all'intersezione tra
diverse discipline come nel mio caso
ed è solo in questo modo che possiamo
sperare in un futuro si spera non troppo
lontano di riuscire a seguire la ricetta
perfetta della prescrizione antibiotica
ovvero l'antibiotico corretto al
paziente corretto al momento corretto
[Applauso]
[Musica]